>> Laura: REMEMBER LAST NIGHT
WE TOLD YOU ABOUT JOE BIDEN'S
PROBLEMS WITH WOKE IMMIGRATION
ACTIVISTS.
ON TONIGHT'S EPISODE OF OUR THEY
LEFT ENOUGH, WE TURN TO
PETE BUTTIGIEG.
HE'S UNDER FIRE FOR SAYING THIS
IN 2011.
>> KIDS NEED TO SEE EVIDENCE
THAT EDUCATION IS WORKING FOR
THEM.
THERE ARE A LOT OF KIDS,
ESPECIALLY IN LOWER INCOME
MINORITY NEIGHBORHOODS WHO
HAVEN'T SEEN IT WORK.
THERE ISN'T SOMEBODY THEY KNOW
PERSONALLY AND I THINK IT
TESTIFIES TO THE VALUE OF
EDUCATION.
>> Laura: THAT RESURFACED
VIDEO, HE LOOKS 12 AND IT HAS
THE RADICAL LEFT RILED UP.
ACTIVIST W, LOBEL TWEETING THAT
MAYOR PETE IS GOING FOR LESS
THAN 0% OF AFRICAN-AMERICAN
SUPPORT.
HERE TO REACT, CANDACE OWENS
AUTHOR OF THE FORTHCOMING BOOK
BLACKOUT ALONG WITH SCOTT BOWEN,
FORMER CHAIR OF THE D.C.
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
HE'S ALREADY OUT APOLOGIZING FOR
THAT COMMENT.
HOW CAN ANYONE SURVIVE THE
DEMOCRATIC LEFT IS THE BUZZ SAW?
>> IT'S SIMPLE, ALL YOU HAVE TO
DO IS NOT TELL THE TRUTH.
HE MADE THE MISTAKE OF TELLING
THE TRUTH, A LOT OF MINORITY
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING, LITERACY
RATES ARE AN ACTUAL EPIDEMIC
HAPPENING IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN YOU SPEAK THE
TRUTH YOU GET YOUR ENTIRE CAREER
ASSASSINATED BY THE LEFT BECAUSE
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO STAND UP
AND TELL THE TRUTH.
>> HE SAID YOU NEEDED IMAGES OF
POSITIVE PEOPLE WERE EDUCATION
PAYS OFF, HE WASN'T TALKING
ABOUT LITERACY.
>> I KNOW HE DIDN'T, HE SAID
EDUCATION SYSTEM DOESN'T WORK
FOR THE MINORITY PEOPLE.
>> BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
POSITIVE IMAGES AND EDUCATION
PAYING OFF, THAT'S IGNORANCE IF
YOU ASK ME.
IF HE THINKS THAT POOR BLACK
CHILDREN IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
CHALLENGED COMMUNITIES ARE THERE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE POSITIVE
IMAGES, I'M IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND I'M A POSITIVE IMAGE, THEY
SUFFER FROM UNDERFUNDING OF
SCHOOLS, SYSTEMIC RACISM.
EDUCATION, HUNGER.
>> Laura: LET ME GO BACK TO
CHICAGO.
WHEN WE ARRIVED THERE IN LATE
SEPTEMBER, THE TEACHERS STRIKE
WITH AUTHORIZE, IT WENT ON FOR A
COUPLE WEEKS.
THEY I BELIEVE ARE THE HIGHEST
PAID TEACHERS IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY WERE ALREADY PREVIOUSLY THE
HIGHEST-PAID.
YOU TALK TO THE FAITH COMMUNITY
LEADERS IN SOUTHSIDE ENGLEWOOD,
ALL THEY TALK ABOUT IS
EDUCATION.
IT'S DANGEROUS TO GO TO SCHOOL,
THEY HAVE A LOT OF DRUG DEALERS
ON THE CORNER, A LOT OF
GANG BANGERS ON THE CORNER, I
THINK THAT'S WHAT HE WAS
PROBABLY GETTING AT.
OBAMA DID MY BROTHER'S KEEPER
AND HE SAID MEN NEED TO STAND UP
IN THE INNER-CITY AND BE STRONG
MALE ROLE MODELS, HE SAID THAT,
ISN'T THAT WHAT PETE BUTTIGIEG
IS SAYING?
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
DON'T WANT BLACK AMERICA TO GET
BETTER.
>> I DO WANT THEM TO GET BETTER.
THE PROBLEM WITH BUTTIGIEG AS HE
SPEAKS WITH AUTHORITY AND HE
KNOWS NOT.
HE TALKS ABOUT THESE STRONG
BLACK MALE IMAGES, THAT'S THE
PROBLEM.
IT'S ALL THE THINGS YOU JUST
NAMED IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
COMPETE WITH THOSE TYPES OF
MENTORS.
>> Laura: YOU THINK THERE ARE
ENOUGH STRONG MALE ROLE MODELS
AND FATHER FIGURES IN
UNDERPRIVILEGED AREAS?
>> ABSOLUTELY, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
LIMIT THAT TO UNDERPRIVILEGED
AREA TO BE A ROLE MODEL AT ALL.
>> THE SINGLE PARENT RATE IS
74%.
I'LL LET YOU TALK.
THE SINGLE MOTHER RATE IS 74%
AND YOU ARE PRETENDING THERE ARE
STRONG MALE FIGURES, YOU'VE
JOINED THE SIDE OF THE
DELUSIONAL.
THIS IS WHY THE BLACK COMMUNITY
WON'T GET BETTER, WE HAVE A
PROBLEM WE NEED TO GET BETTER,
THE EDUCATION, WE NEED FATHERS
BACK IN THE HOME.
THIS IS WHY REPUBLICANS AND
CONSERVATIVES ARE WINNING
BECAUSE WE TELL THE TRUTH.
>> THE IDEA THAT BLACK PEOPLE
ALL COME FROM BROKEN FAMILIES,
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> Laura: WE HAVE SCOTT BOLDEN
AND WE HAVE BARACK OBAMA BUT
THEY AREN'T IN PEOPLE'S LIVES
EVERY DAY.
I THINK THAT'S THE POINT HE WAS
TRYING TO GET AT AND WE ALL NEED
THAT.
>> THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THEM IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES AND WHAT ABOUT
SOCIAL ORGANIZATIONS WHO DO
MENTORSHIP?
IT'S MORE THAN THAT.
>> Laura: I THINK HE WOULD SAY
IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
THERE ARE OTHER ISSUES.
WE HAVE TO PLAY BUTTIGIEG'S
COMMENTS TODAY WHICH WAS A
SIGNIFICANT WALK BACK.
>> WHAT I SAID IN THAT COMMENT
BEFORE I BECAME MAYOR DOES NOT
REFLECT THE TOTALITY OF MY
UNDERSTANDING THEN AND CERTAINLY
NOW ABOUT THE OBSTACLES THAT
STUDENTS OF COLOR FACE IN OUR
SYSTEM TODAY.
>> Laura: WILL
>> Laura: RILL
>> Laura: REAL QUICK, WHAT IS
HE SAYING?
>> THIS IS WHY PEOPLE PREFER
TRUMP BECAUSE TRUMP DOES NOT
WALK BACK ON TELLING THE TRUTH.
WHEN YOU BREAK DOWN THE FAMILY
UNIT WHICH HAS BEEN DONE
STRATEGICALLY, THE CHILDREN ONE
TO THE STREETS.
THEIR IDOLS BECOME CULTURAL
ICONS, PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHO YOU
ARE IN BLACK AMERICA BUT I BET
YOU THEY KNOW WHO ALL THE
RAPPERS ARE.
WE HAVE CAP LEADERS WHO HAVE
THIS MIND TO ADMIT THAT.
>> WE HAVE SO MANY STRONG BLACK
MEN IN BLACK WOMEN WHETHER THEY
KNOW ME OR BARACK OBAMA OR NOT,
WHETHER THEY ARE HARDWORKING
PEOPLE, THAT THESE KIDS CAN LOOK
UP TO.
PEOPLE NEED TO CARE ABOUT THESE
KIDS, INVEST IN THESE KIDS, YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BE A CULTURAL ICON
TO DO THAT.
IF YOU THINK THAT'S THE ONLY
PROBLEM IS BECAUSE YOU HAVE
BROKEN FAMILIES, THERE ARE A LOT